now back in the early 90s specialty
hardware was used to get smooth graphics
on early machines things like the NES
Genesis and Gameboy had custom hardware
that was built into the form factor that
was allowed you to draw tons and tons of
tiles very quickly on modern screens now
desktop computers at the time didn't
have that much power in fact they didn't
have any of that specialty hardware at
all modern desktops around that time
running at 33 Hertz were considered
top-of-the-line now one day a young John
Carmack made a demo called dangerous
Dave and copyright infringement which
actually showed off a Super Mario
Brothers 3 level running at full 30
frames a second on desktop hardware
he showed that demo to a young John
Romero in that very day edie software
was born the same studio that went on to
actually create the first-person shooter
genre with titles such as Wolfenstein
doom and quake now the trick that
Carmack realized to get the same
performance from the specialty hardware
on the desktop was actually an
optimization see these early machines
weren't too good at actually copying
pixels over here to over here in memory
was actually a pretty difficult concepts
especially with the bitmap colors and
everything but what they were good at
was actually just copying rows of memory
from different registers so what Carmack
realized was if he could use the
previous frame and somehow just use mem
copies to sort of shift it so that it
looks like the scene is actually
scrolling they need to be able to only
have to update the small portion of the
screen that changed as your character
was moving thus was born the concept of
dirty rect now this is the same concept
that's been used today in tons and tons
of games see that's the trick with game
industry techniques like this they never
really die they just kind of get
rebranded as technology evolves over
time